yesterday we participated in a lot of
well-prepared talks about artificial
intelligent deep learning data and the
problem with data we have to handle with
today we are going combine all those
things together to provide you a real
case of study of our project and I
believe that we can do it in the best
audience I can imagine
so I mapped insta Xavier I'm working as
a senior software developer at Capgemini
Poland and I Miho Dora it's in your big
data engineer come to me Poland so
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon okay
so the topic of our speech is the smart
shopping basket before will go to
technical details and implementation
stuff we would like to give you a short
business introduction to the topic
basically that some overview the reason
why we have chosen this this topic and
why we have decided to build some smart
shopping basket it's not a secret that
offline retailers have much more
challenges to handle than online shops
and once we will do this distinguished
distinguishing between offline and
online shops we can see that online
shops have much more possibilities to
use advanced analytics to generate more
data and use it further to do some
better data science a product and offer
it offer a better product to the
customer and our goal was to find some
solution that will also enable these
possibilities for offline retailers and
the best example are recommendations and
cross-selling basically I think everyone
here is aware that once we will once we
will log to some online store and once
we will
some product we are we have this
recommendation in sections where we can
have some next best offers proposed by
the online retailers and this means that
basically once we we are locked into the
online shop we are being trucked and our
behavior is well-known for the retailer
and it can be used to predict some
products and give us a better overview
what do we really need but such thing is
very hard to achieve for all offline
stores because basically they're the the
shop the supermarket knows nothing why
we are here what do we want to buy they
know only think these things when we are
staying in a queue tube to the cutter
desk and when we pay for products we
have chosen so basically we asked
ourselves a question what do we need to
change to make offline retailers life
much easier and we have found one think
that the biggest limitation is a
shopping cart so basically we do not
want to remove a shopping cart from
supermarkets but we would like to
propose to upgrade it to the version 2.0
to the smart shopping cart that is here
with us this is our product and we think
that it enables customers and offline
offline shops a better prediction better
behavior and better analytics in the
future professor Andrew I have a great
chance to meet him in San Francisco
during the conference in mind this year
said that there is a great task to move
artificial intelligence from the cloud
to the IOT devices to the edge we can
say what does it mean doesn't mean that
for us data scientists this is real
normal just quite normal that the place
to make AI is the cloud because we have
their GPU we have their efficient
CPUs or something like this but now the
great task is to switch our thinking
from the cloud to the AI IOT okay so
let's look at the barriers we have to do
it so I can imagine that you are
familiar with deep learning so you know
that deep learning model are very large
we need a lot of computing power to
train this model and also to evaluate
normal to evaluate deep learning model
in real time on production I can say we
need also a GPU yeah
CPU the CPU is not enough for us so
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
please welcome word first AI accelerator
in USB format what is it it is Intel
more videos neural computing stick you
can see at the image and our board
Raspberry Pi we used what we used we
used Raspberry Pi Intel my videos and my
camera to classify detect and recognize
products intro videos is small this is a
great advantage I can say it allows us
to perform a lot of AI tasks at the edge
not in the cloud directly for example on
the Raspberry Pi board so the key
feature is ultra power design the power
from USB port is enough to perform deep
learning
it is very friendly for tensorflow and
coffee and we don't need to connect with
cloud when we want to classify something
and the other advantage is that when we
have for example six USB ports you can
use six Intel more videos as a matrix to
provide the scalability and efficiency
so what are the key capabilities for in
term of videos we can use it to face
recognition now
with processing to object detection to
image classification and also to music
generation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now it's time to show you how we
all the work you know means you look
only once you only look once what does
it mean that normally when we have
regular irregular and recurrent networks
they can also classify images we can use
CNN's Erin ants on something like this
but they are great they are working but
the key thing is that first those
networks try to find a lot of squares at
the image and then they try to classify
first square second third and so on and
so forth yeah
it is very time-consuming and to find
maybe two product on the image we need
to perform maybe 1,000 classifications
yellow is the algorithm that we can
recognize product only when we look once
at the image okay let's take an example
this very simple example this is real
photo we created we can see five
products is an ordinal image what we
need is to split the image into the grid
into the squares and then for each
square we need to produce two things the
one things
the one thing is for example two uncle
boxes this is for example an area where
the one so think that there is a product
and also we need to predict produce the
second thing which is the probability
does this square belongs to given
product for example here does this
square belongs to the autoshi drink okay
maybe now you can see the 2 anchor boxes
at the origin drink and we can also
produce the anchor boxes for the area
where there is no product okay why not
we did it okay then we also although all
the time we should maintain the grid we
have a lot of anchor boxes for each so
we have the many many many bunch of our
anchor boxes and then at the left hand
side we have anchor boxes and and the
right hand side we have the
probabilities that the given small
square belong to the given product and
what we need we have to multiply anchor
boxes time the probabilities and what we
have it is the weighted anchor boxes and
now what the last thing what we need to
address is to threshold to choose only
the higher value of anchor boxes and
those are our products okay how we can
train train our algorithm this is I
think this is known for you that the
training is not on raspberry pi but on
the server with GPIO so let's look at
the code behind me you can see that the
host name host name is Atlantis this is
our GPO computer without the X on board
what we have is - we have some files we
have a training file with the training
data test the data label names label and
those are for example Pepsi coca-cola or
something like this images those are
images docker file is to use a docker
and there is also a darknet file with
pre-trained white on the image net this
is a quite look at the training data
labels data for example the name of
product was now docker file docket for
is to produce to maintain
reproducibility and to provide us every
for it for you can repeat our
research and what we need is to check
out a darknet repository darkened is the
original implementation in the C
language so what we need those are
labels and what we need is to build a
docker image why because we provide a
custom docker file we do a research-only
with docker because we want to be
independent from the our operating
system so we need to build a docker we
built it
a few second ago so we don't need to do
it now what we need there is to run the
Nvidia docker comment and if you had
ocher command is very similar to the
docker comment but inside the container
we want to use our lax GPU so that's why
we use Nvidia and darker we use this
mapping this is a volume mapping to
provide the data into the container and
the data use solve ten second ago and at
the end we want to run the bash command
ok now we are in inside the container
you can see the host name has been
changed this is this is container so
what we need is to check if we can see
the data you saw before okay we have and
you can't see anything why I don't know
I hope that you can see it now so what
we need is to create our architecture
okay we can borrow Architecture from the
outers and we have to change some things
we have to change a batch file we have
to change subdivisions just for example
how many examples we can show for our
network we need to change also how many
classes how much classes we have and we
need to change also the filters number
okay so we are pretty and then so this
is also one file we have to create is
this data file when we can
increase or indicate where the training
data
where are the test data and the label
names okay so we're done and now we are
ready to train our algorithm what does
it mean does it mean that we can create
a command darknet train we can pass our
data file then we can pass another file
this is a config this architecture how
many layers how many runs on something
like this and then their heat actor was
printed and the training has started so
it was at our on our GPU computer so now
how we can deploy this model on the
raspberry and on the intel more videos
we are now on the Raspberry Pi computer
as you can see the train algorithm has
produced the weight file the last file
here here is the way it's file and this
is the output from our algorithm the
basket config this is a file yourself
before these are architectural labels
names isn't also known for you and from
the weight file we have to produce the
those file this is very simple you can
use it you can use the dark net or dark
flow for it and now what is important we
have to use Intel
development kit this is our library you
can download dedicated for Intel more
videos to compile your training model to
the Intel more videos architecture in
term of videos contain very efficient
visual processors so you have to compile
your model your trained model into the
Intel more videos architecture visual
processing unit so that's why we called
the command
and now the training now the compilation
has been started so what do you need to
create such file unit and Intel more
videos and you need a library download
download it for the Intel webpage to
create such such file ok and in a few
seconds you will see the file which is
called graph this is a ready to load in
Intel more videos file you can see in
your new green line this is yellow
basket teeny tiny basket graph and this
graph is ready to load at the interim of
videos so how we can evaluate the model
on Raspberry Pi ok
it's very easy what we need is to
Raspberry Pi and now yeah you can see
that this is a Raspberry Pi and now what
we need is to load the graph file we
generate previously into the USB stick
called into more videos so now we will
show you our code in which we capture an
image we communicate with AWS to get
recommendations
I mean how will tell you something about
it and we also need to load the graph
into them into more videos so this is
the file I mentioned so you can see in
Tallulah tiny object graph you can see
directly dictionary with classes and
what is important the most important
thing is the main method the field lines
are communication with AWS there we have
to initialize raspberry pi camera the
dedicated camera for raspberry and the
next step is to run intel more videos
this is for example to initialize
internal more videos device with
detective the in term of videos devices
plug-in and then from the entomologist
device we need to take and and object we
just would corresponds to that to the to
this device this for example an object
which represented which is an interface
for this for this USB stick and then
having this object we can load our graph
file we pre-compiled previously into the
device and this is here exactly there
you can see this is a for loop yeah this
is a loop when we in which we they we
are taking all those images from
Raspberry Pi camera and we are passing
that each image to the Intel mo videos
okay hi Intel more videos please produce
for me recommendations please detect all
the all those object and all computation
related with deep learning are performed
inside the USB stick but not inside that
raspberry pie processor and here you can
see we are asking each time for each
image we are asking USB stick to detect
new objects so now is the cloud part so
me how so few slides ago
we've talked that it's good to bring
computations to the edge from cloud but
in our solution with used cloud as well
basically the entire architecture looks
like following on the left side we have
the smart shopping basket so the entire
IOT solution this is raspberry pi with
into the more videos the camera and
display and on the right side we have
AWS components we've decided to use AWS
IOT core and AWS lambda so right now
here comes the challenge how to
integrate this all things together a
before we'll talk about it a few details
about AWS components because maybe not
everyone is familiar with that the IOT
core module is
solution on AWS cloud that allows us to
collect different IOT devices to the
cloud so basically we are able to send
some messages some data from IOT devices
to the cloud and between IOT devices in
a network and also what's really
important from our perspective is the
fact that we can it support
bi-directional communication so we can
not only send data from IOT to AWS but
we can also send data from AWS to IOT
device the communication can be done via
protocols for example MQTT HTTP and MQTT
with WebSocket in our case we've decided
to use mqtt and what's also quite
important is the fact that it's
serverless it means that we do not need
to maintain hardware we do not need to
think about things like scalability and
maintaining the the technical part we
just can focus on coding and the core
functionality on our application and the
rest is not important for us ok on the
other hand we need some component also
on IOT device to establish the
communication with AWS here we have used
the library AWS IOT device SDK for
Python because the entire development
we've prepared in Python language this
is a small teaser and basically all
important methods we used connect to
establish a connection with a given MQTT
topic a subscribe to be able to receive
messages sent on AWS IOT core and
publish that allows us to send some
messages to AWS so the first step is to
establish connection between the smart
shopping basket and AWS IOT core for
that we have used MQTT and we have
created topic called products so every
time when the new item is placed to the
basket and this item is recognized there
is a message for example that this is a
napple this information is sent via this
MQTT topic to AWS IOT the type of a
message is a JSON so the structure is
quite simple this is how it looks like
so we have an information which device
sent this message and what was
recognized in this case product a and
AWS IOT once the message is published on
a queue is a triggering lambda function
lambda is a solution on AWS that allows
us to run code without servers
so again serverless all advantages that
we have described for IOT core are also
valid here lab that triggers computation
immediately so we can achieve new
real-time solution and the code is
executed only when needed so it means we
do not need to maintain the servers and
etc every time we just pay for the time
when we really compute something and it
has a great integration with tensorflow
there are a bunch of articles how to
deploy tensor flow models on AWS lambda
and we also decided to use it in our
solution so the first model the yellow
algorithm is deployed directly on IOT
device on the smart basket however in
AWS lambda we have used the
recommendation engine that is generating
recommendation based on the information
that was received from the smart
shopping basket and as soon as the AWS
lambda gives us the information about
the recommendation it's sent back to AWS
IOT core and here on MQTT topic advise a
different one which is which the smart
shopping is subscribing we are sending
the recommendation and once the
recommendation is sent automatically on
a small screen that is installed on the
smart shopping basket the image is
displayed with the information which
product is recommended this is a JSON
file that is sent between a IOT core and
AWS
on a advice topic so almost the same
structure as previously okay so it's
time for short demo yeah it's great it's
time for short demo I have to refresh my
web page
yeah I need this web drop it on my PC so
I will show you another webpage because
there are the letters are very small so
what I need is to connect with the with
my device using the URL address but
before I will do this I will show you
the demo using using this presentation
what can you see here is the I will show
you there ok here you can see how we can
recognize the objects so we can see that
we cannot code nice paragraph for
example the paper the water banana
something like this in its probably in
it position yeah and also when we for
example get pond inside the pepper the
recommendation that the next product
that for example an egg is has been
generated and now I have to connect with
my with my device one second ok
because we have our own Wi-Fi to do it
it's a bit time consuming so we are
quite ready
okay
okay so for example here you can see
those are a little bit frozen that in
real time we can recognize for example
that we have two product in our in our
basket and for example when I look move
wonder product backward for example here
there is a problem but because the light
is here not so enough but you can see
that okay it's good the left product
left the this is the left-hand side your
right hand side product okay it is a
camera problem but you saw that for
example only using the camera and the
yellow algorithm we can find where the
product is on only based on the shape
and color this is not important for
example that there is no logo for
example yeah okay we can use for example
here you see the two sweets to kind of
sweets the one tweaks you can see the
logo but the another sweet you you can
see a logo but we can see the shape we
can see the color of the sweet and we
can make a prediction what product is
inside for example we have also some
other products if you have time we can
show you something more after our
presentation so now I think it's time to
say thank you for coming
and maybe you have some questions we can
answer thank you
[Applause]
one very short one question is what is
the price of these sticks or there are
any additions or versions mmm I can
answer this question currently there are
two versions the version 1 and version 2
since three months we have the version 2
which is more computing power so the
price is $100 I think at the eBay or
Amazon shop store you can buy it but in
Poland I didn't see it an delivers but
using Amazon or maybe official Intel
webpage you can order those things ok so
big thanks to our speakers I think we
don't have time for any more questions
so please ask them individually yep
thank you look at this
[Applause]